All right, so listen up. Republicans are going
to try or better said they are trying to steal
that Kentucky gubernatorial election that
they lost, which I told you about yesterday.
By the way, big interest in my story yesterday
about the big wins by Democrats on Tuesday
evening and a bunch of different state and
local elections. Usually the stories where
I talk about local and state elections and
the implications that they just don't do that
well. But I got dozens of emails from yesterday's
close to 100,000 views on YouTube and just
like the first 12 hours. So this is a good
sign that people are engaged with the races
that are going on. So one of those races was
the Kentucky gubernatorial race in Kentucky,
a very red state, which Donald Trump won by
30 points over. Hillary Clinton in 2016 had
a Trump loving governor named Matt bell gubernatorial
candidate named Matt Bevin. A major democratic
victory has taken place with democratic challenger,
Andy Beshear, the attorney general of the
state, knocking out the incumbent Republican
governor.
Now this is Kentucky. It's not a blue state.
It's not a purple state. And officially at
this point in time, it is a blue victory in
a very red state. By 5,189 votes for Andy
Bashir, the Republicans are going to fight
to the end to steal the election. And here's
how they're going to do it. First of all,
as as a mere formality, the governor has refused
to concede. Now again, as I've said before,
concessions don't really do anything. But
later on it can be pointed to, to try to build
the case that they from the beginning didn't
believe that they had actually lost. Okay.
Because of the small margin, they are going
to demand that the entire state be re canvased
as it's called, because of concerns that they
are generally talking about regarding voting
irregularities. Now, the thing is, they're
not telling us what those irregularities are.
Uh, they say quote, we want the people of
Kentucky to have absolute confidence that
their votes were counted as they should have
been counted, but there is no indication about
why someone would suspect that their vote
was not counted. And there's also no specific
claims or evidence that have been presented
that anyone's votes were not counted, particularly
in a way that would have hurt the democratic
candidate, uh, or helped the democratic candidate
as counted, but would help the Republican
candidate if they had been counted the correct
way. But the whole point of all of this is
not even to get the re canvassing to change
the results because it is unlikely that re
canvasing would flip 5,189 votes, which is
the margin of victory. So what's the real
point here? The point is they want to escalate
the entire process to the state legislature,
which is controlled by Republicans because
section 90 of the Kentucky constitution says,
quote, contested elections for governor and
Lieutenant governor shall be determined by
both houses of the general assembly according
to such regulations as may be established
by the law.
So understand that all of this is premised
on supposedly voting irregularities which
were not reported on election day and which
the Republicans refused to actually give us
any examples of, Bernie is furious saying
quote, in a democracy, we can not allow politicians
to just overrule the election results, the
vote, the will of the voters must be respected.
Now this is a very long shot, especially since
even if the state legislature does get to
decide, they still need to establish, establish
some fixed process for how it's all going
to be carried out. It's not just they pick
the winner and they pick the Republican, but
it is still a last ditch effort and they are
extraordinarily desperate and the most likely
way I'm guessing that they would try to make
some kind of progress is to make some kind
of argument about the libertarian candidate
supposedly getting 2% of the votes and that's
larger than the margin of victory for the
Democrat.
And they will probably try to say there is,
you know, there were, there were votes credited
to the libertarian that were met for the Republican
or whatever. I mean, none of this stuff makes
any sense. I'm just thinking ahead to what
they're most likely to do. If it sounds absurd
and ridiculous to you, it's because it is
absurd and ridiculous, but they don't care.
The means always justify the ends if it keeps
a Democrat out of office, even if the Democrat
one, so we're going to be watching this one
very closely. There's a lot of coverage about
this one on common dreams, daily COEs and
a lot of other activists, lefty websites.
It's on Bernie Sanders radar. So hopefully,
um, it will not lend itself to a situation
where Republicans can actually pull this off,
but they are furious. They see what Tuesday
night's election results potentially mean
for them in 2020 they see what it means to
start losing state houses and governors mansions
in red States across the country.
Virginia turned totally blue. There were interesting
results in some parts of Pennsylvania that
are traditionally red that I did not get to
on Tuesday night, which a lot of people emailed
me about and are important and and we hopefully
will get a chance to talk about at some point
so they see what is going on. Whether they
attribute it to being damaged by Trump or
not. It depends on which Republicans you talk
to. Some of them do, some of them don't. But
this is potentially going to be a bloodbath
in 2020 but I don't want a single one of you
to hear me say that and believe that now you
can rest on your laurels and not have to work
our asses off for 2020 we could take the Senate
back. It's an uphill battle, but I outlined
how it could happen, but it's only if we really
work in all of those important States where
there are elections that could go from Republican
to Democrat.
We could knock out Donald Trump, but it's
going to come down to actually getting out
the vote in those key battleground States
that I told you about yesterday. It could
look really good or it could be another four
years of a Republican Senate and Donald Trump
in the white house. That's a a real possibility
if we don't actually do what we need to do.